Here we are.
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know, your life is different now.
Straight is out. What a confusing statement. Squiggles are in. if you guys haven't seen there's this trend of squiggle eyebrows and
Squiggle lips happening, and I'm not better than any of that so I thought I'll jump on that bandwagon
I did high jump in high school
I'm very good at jumping, but I'm gonna raise it up a notch and I'm gonna try and do a full face of squiggles
What does that mean? I don't know?
I haven't fully thought this through we're just gonna wing it or squiggle it no winged eyeliner here get out of here
Let's just do this. I have Foundation and concealer already on my face so that step is done
I guess the first thing we're gonna do we're gonna try some squiggle eyebrows gonna use this Revlon Colorstay brow pencil that I have that
Is too dark for my eyebrows normally, but might work better for this scenario, so let's try that let me use the mirror
That's in this thing
I'm assuming that you just draw the squiggles, and then you color them in I've seen people like cut their brows into squiggles, too
But look I've cut my bangs twice. I'm not here for that anymore
I'm in a better place emotionally all right, so let's just try and draw some squiggle. Oh, yeah, it's sort of starting-
I get when makeup gurus can't talk and do their makeup at the same time, okay. I think I found the flow
That not so much a squiggle as like someone doing a bad dive into a pool. Cute.
Okay, that's a little bit more squiggle
I'm gonna try my other brow product to see if it blends it better. Kabrow by benefit that I love so much
Maybe should have started with it
That really didn't help very much, but let's move on to the other eyebrow whoa
these look like two
ghost Buffalo's charging at each other cute. It's already taking shape in the shape is a squiggle. It just it's this shape now
Let's squiggle our eyeliner
I'm just gonna take some liquid liner that I have and see if we can make some squiggles
This one's gonna be the bad one. I think I'll just squiggle the top oh not easy
Why did we try this can you see that my hands are shaking.
Like, there's no consequence to doing this but for some reason I'm very nervous
I want you guys to think I'm good at something what that something is. I don't know oh come for me boys
She's ready, that's squiggled. Let's squiggle the other eye. Okay before it gets out of hand. Let's move on
Oh, we squiggle our eyeliner. Okay now
Just put some mascara on can't really squiggle that now I wanted to try squiggling blush
But I don't think it's gonna show up very well. I have this Stila blush.Let's try using like a fine
tool, oh okay that oh
Maybe this is a look good summer look. Blend it out a little bit
Oh wow, I mean contour for the gods in hell because this is a nightmare here we go okay, other side.
Oh, yeah, one tool if I give two weird hives for me on the side of your face. Next.
Let's try the same for bronzer. We're use the same brush
Yes, there. We go wow wow wow wow okay very tribal meets a carnival finally
We're gonna squiggle our lips
I'm going to use this Too Faced melted matte liquefied matte long-wear lipstick from Candy Johnson's new line with Too Faced
I don't know if this is the best way for me to be demonstrating her product, but hi candy. I love this lipstick
I'm gonna use it here now. We're just gonna try and squiggle like we've been doing this whole time
It's good when you want to overdraw your lips to give them a bigger shape than you have naturally oh
Yes yes
So we kind of f*cked up the bottom part of the lips a little bit, but
You get the picture. I don't wanna mess with it too much more
Well, let me just touch it a second more okay, and there we go there's our full face of squiggle makeup
What do you guys think let me know hmm? I mean it's really impressive
I know I'm impressed
Look at this leave a comment down below what you guys think and what you would call this look
I think I would call this squiggly puff
I'm very dehydrated
So I'm retaining water and my face is a little puffy if you guys liked this video give it a thumbs up and click that
Subscribe button cuz I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes sometimes. I don't I don't know
Wow mm-hmm yeah, I feel like a failed Pokemon or like a sperm that went drag